Hello Freak bitches.
So that's a massive sacrifice you're
willing to take to be,
to do that.
And this,
the fact that it's exists inside your
body for an undetermined state of time.
That's um,
that's pretty wild,
man.
It's,
it's scary.
Um,
yeah.
Honestly I feel like I was in a much
scarier place personally,
um,
before,
before I found this before I found them
before I got given a second family or
accepted into a second family and more
scarier because you were depressed
because he just will depress suicidal
thoughts.
I had for like 10 years,
just battle it from 13 years old,
23 and so,
um,
yeah,
that,
that was a lot scarier to me than going
home to his huddle thoughts when you're
13.
Yeah,
for sure.
And I,
I mean,
I was,
I was the one that like,
you know,
the kid in the,
in the class that,
I mean,
I wasn't,
I wasn't like,
I wouldn't say I was,
how do I say?
It was extremely brutal,
but it was happening to,
I mean,
everyone gets bullied for the most part.
Um,
somebody who's bullying you.
Yeah.
Well when I was growing up that from
from third grade until eighth grade for
sure it was brutal.
70 Dalton usually smaller than I was
here.
Dude,
I was smaller.
It takes a lot of balls to bully you.
Yeah.
And my backfire,
it's actually kind of why I found
fighting or net.
Why or it is kind.
It is because uh,
I was 13 years old and I had just gotten
so,
well two things.
Have you ever seen in Texas for high
school homecomings?
They have mums,
have you heard of that?
No.
It's a mom is tradition.
That's crazy.
Um,
now all,
all,
all the kids love him,
everything else.
But you get these like Chris Hodges or
fake flowers that they put real big up
top and then they are streamers with
literal bells and whistles,
full size teddy bears.
You can have two,
three teddy bears.
And when I was in high school,
the girl would wear it on her shoulder
and the guy would weird round his arm.
Now in Texas,
they literally have to put a harness
around them and hold these things up
because they're so big.
And there you go.
Mom texted him on Fox.
That's homecoming in Texas.
Why?
Look at that.
I'm telling you it's an example.
State the whole state.
I mean every heard of the every
homecoming that comes around tech Texans
are nuts about this.
I mean I lived in Texas and I was like
four months old,
so it was a there nuts in,
they've gotten bigger and bigger and
bigger every single year.
And uh,
how am I just hearing about the proud of
it?
It's weird.
I mean I I you just hearing about this
Jamie,
I think those are literally like two and
$300.
No,
not,
yeah.
When I was in high school they were like
7,000 all my God,
look at all those girls.
Look at that picture that you had done
there.
There's a giant group of girls with all
this.
This is ridiculous.
That not nuts.
How do you,
how do you go to the dance like that?
How do you go to the game like that?
I don't understand.
I mean literally the boyfriends are
walking behind him,
holding the stuff up for him because
what the,
it's getting too heavy or their neck
hurts,
but they want to wear it.
It's a tradition.
Yeah.
Everybody gets excited.
The bigger and the bigger the mum,
the better.
The more,
the more your date.
Like do you,
is this a mum company that you just
clicked on every single grocery store in
Texas?
Whenever it comes to like a September,
October,
November,
around homecoming time,
high school,
like this is people's jobs,
like seasonal jobs.
He sit around and they take special
orders.
They make them for you or they sound
where he can make them yourself.
Um,
that's so strange,
isn't it nuts?
How many is this?
It always baffles me when I find out
about something for the very first time.
I don't know why I'm so confused.
I would like to find out where the
tradition came from probably.
But I mean,
people,
it's just so ingrained in you.
If you're texting,
they have to get moms.
And so,
uh,
is there any other states?
Find out if other states except that I
literally the Oklahoma doesn't do it.
Louisiana doesn't New Mexico,
I mean times 12 things non Texas need to
know about homecoming moms.
Uh,
what in the fuck mom started as a simple
flower.
Hold on,
scroll up a little bit.
Mum started as a simple flower guys,
give them to their homecoming date.
Oh that's hilarious.
Girls also give guys one called a
garter.
Like a garter.
Oh,
they put it on your,
on your arm when garter belt on over
your side.
How buzz.
Like one of those things that Thai
boxing where yeah,
being able to make moms can make you
rich.
Oh God.
See 60 to $300.
What?
$300 for fake flowers on her bucks.
It ain't cheap to electrify a mom.
Oh my God.
That chick's got home and lights up.
That's so crazy.
You could put led lighting.
Look at that scroll and Scroll up a
little bit,
but you can put led lighting and mum's,
I didn't know how many folks are doing
this back when I was in high school,
but nowadays you really want to impress
your date,
the latest and mum lighting technology
will help you do just that.
That is hilarious.
You know,
this isn't even like a joke website
right now.
Was a cereal to taking it serious.
So strange.
[inaudible]
it's really weird.
And so when I was in middle school,
seventh grade,
I,
you know,
look at that girl,
she's got a Christmas tree on her tits.
That's ridiculous.
They,
uh,
so you want to save,
I saved it up and my allowance asked one
of my crushes to go to the homecoming
game with me.
She said yes,
to my surprise,
I went to the game and,
uh,
spent pretty much all my allowance on,
the her mom and,
uh,
her name's Jessica and I took her to the
game and I'm up in the stands with her
and home or halftime comes around,
I'm up to the very top left and all of a
sudden everyone looks back up over the
right shoulders at us.
And this one guy,
he's kind of my,
my belief through elementary and middle
school for sure.
And um,
his name was justin as well.
And so he walks up and puts his arm out
to her and she puts her arm around his
and he grabs the streamer that says,
uh,
Justin and Jessica and a year on it or
whatever.
And uh,
he says,
thanks for getting her this.
And I'm like,
what?
And he goes,
you didn't think she'd come with you,
did you?
And so he just kind of walks down.
All the schools,
look in,
they're all laughing and having fun,
but,
and that one hurt,
but what was worse with the next year?
Cause you know,
people liked that part of,
I don't know,
I think
for me,
when I see bullying now,
I just spoke at a middle school and I
told one of the teachers asked,
what should you tell a kid that's
battling with suicidal thoughts or
depression,
even maybe suicidal thoughts.
And I'm like,
well,
if this is 300,
400 kids in here,
like for sure one person is dealing with
these issues right now.
And I would say,
you know,
um,
the thing that probably saved me was my
parents didn't own a gun.
I'd probably only Texans that don't own
guns.
And uh,
then,
um,
I don't know.
I mean,
I guess one of the main things was,
um,
well I don't even know that I've ever
said this publicly,
but I remember,
um,
uh,
having attempted suicide once and then
I'm thinking about it again and then I'm
thinking,
you know,
what would this,
what would this do to my mom?
You know?
And so I love my Mama.
My Mama's boy,
dad's great too,
but that's just who I am.
She's a tough cookie.
She's where I got my competitiveness.
She was a national champion and barrel
racing state champion in tennis.
And so she always pushed me,
my dad,
if he,
uh,
if he was at a wrestling tournament and
it's the finals even state,
I would dislocate my thumb or something,
he'd come up,
you don't have to wrestle in the next
match.
Like it's the finals.
My Mom's like,
he's getting out there.
So my mom's the one pushing him to shut
up.
Jimmy.
He's gonna,
he's gonna go out there and he's going
to wrestle.
He's going to win.
And so,
uh,
my dad was more of the,
the one who need to protect me and she's
the one wanting to push me out there.
Um,
so I guess,
uh,
I mean,
all I'm saying that except for,
oh,
that thought was just ringing in my
head.
And so whenever I finally verbalized
that and start talking to people,
that's what really helped.
You know,
it didn't have to be a bunch of people.
I didn't have to go around and be,
um,
I don't know,
a drama queen or do it for attention or
whatever,
but just find one person.
And for me at that age,
it was having a great mom and um,
and parents that love me.
And I think that's probably absolutely
what saved me at that time.
And so I was telling these kids,
you know,
hey,
tell if,
even if it's just your mom.
So I was taking pictures with some of
the kids afterwards and stuff and I'll
walk out to leave and I'm in the hall
and this mom stops me because she's with
her little guy and he's crying.
So a mom had come to school and heard
there was anti bullying talk.
She came up and I see this little guy
and reminded me,
a lot of me,
the only difference was,
uh,
was he had these kind of big glasses on,
but he was a little chubby and had just
had one of those things that you'd see
stereotypical like this kid's going to
get picked on.
And so I'm probably a lot like me.
He's used to getting his fat,
pinch tune nipples twisted and you know,
all that different stuff.
And so,
um,
he was out there just bawling with his
mom as Paul.
Massive.
I come talk to them for a little bit.
I did.
And she was saying that he had never
opened up with her and uh,
in the last two years,
but she knew he had been dealing with
really bad depression.
And right there he told her,
I've been dealing with suicidal thoughts
for two years.
And so I don't know why I even brought
that up except for like,
it's nuts.
My parents have a,
have a photography company and they meet
a memorial a few years back for a little
boy.
He was getting bullied,
didn't think he had an option out.
And he took his life at nine years old.
Oh my God.
When I think it was a swing set out
back,
so himself,
Jesus Christ.
And so,
um,
and I saw the plaque and everything made
up for him and just gut wrenching.
And so anyway,
I say that in the first story it wasn't
that,
but from this kind of one that kind of
brought everything to a head was I was
in middle eighth grade this time,
um,
got invited to a Jennifer's,
birthday party.
Really excited.
Got The one of the real limitations in
my hands and,
um,
made the plan stuck to my mom,
asked if I could go and talk to some of
the people who else is going.
That was kind of Dorky kid anyways,
but,
um,
uh,
on the invitation,
I know that man,
it says costume contest and the winner
gets a prize.
Why started in research,
all this other stuff,
other people are doing it too.
And um,
I found out that her dad worked at Dr
Pepper,
um,
in that their house was decorated with
it,
all this other stuff.
And then,
um,
and then the,
she loved transformers.
And so I thought,
what if I combine those two things?
What if I could,
uh,
meet myself a cardboard transformer from
head to toe?
Uh,
I think it was a 24 pack or on the head,
12 packs around the arms,
legs,
boots.
I had,
I had a chest plate at a sword out of a
cardboard,
a country kid texted,
you see those moms?
We can do pretty much anything with duct
tape.
And,
uh,
so duct tape,
cardboard just made it up and walked
into the party and,
um,
her grandma opened the door and she
goes,
oh,
Jennifer's going to love this.
Walked into,
they literally had a Dr Pepper machine
where it was like old school ones you'd
have to pay,
just push the button.
It pops out.
13 year old kid.
You love that.
So we got Dr Pepper.
Can one hand have the Dr Pepper
Cardboard Sword in the other walk to the
backyard.
Um,
when whenever the door opens,
I opened the door and breathe there with
like some flashes of lights and fingers
pointing people laughing.
And um,
I remember Jennifer saying,
I can't believe you thought you were
cool enough to come to my party.
And I was the only one that was dressed
up.
Everybody else had gotten there early
and they all been planning and even the
invitations were fake just so that I
would come there,
dress up at another kid,
said,
um,
you're worthless.
So in that moment it felt worthless.
And then,
um,
the main belief said you should just
kill yourself.
And so whenever he said that 13 years
old battle with depression and suicidal
thoughts,
all the different stuff in it,
it took me on a downward spiral
tailspin.
Um,
it really sucked.
I didn't know how to cover it up.
And then I guess I'm getting back to
them and may route where I found that 13
years old at like a flea market in Texas
and walking down these aisles and
looking for a bb gun and all of a sudden
get to the site used video shop and it's
got UFC vhs.
I think it was two through 10 or 10,
two through 11 or something like that.
And I'm so I just,
my bottom wall,
um,
you were on there and a is a horrible
story,
man.
That is a terrible story.
How the fuck does kids be so mean?
I mean,
I thought he's,
honestly,
I,
I don't think it's,
I mean that crazy compared to,
I mean it is,
it's very like a methodical,
like very planned out and a lot of
people were in on it.
I think that probably was one of the
things like,
honestly,
Jennifer was that the biggest crush I
ever had and you know,
elementary,
middle school growing up,
you know,
and so she was the one that really
wanted to impress.
That's why I did that research,
you know,
and then to know that she was in on it,
these other guys planned it,
but she went along with it,
um,
to her to have her say that to you,
like the,
I can't believe you thought you were
cool enough to come to my party.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
I ended up leaving.
Um,
and this is before cell phones.
Uh,
and I didn't have a cell phone until I
was like 16 and 17,
and I'm,
so I'm 13 run out,
found a dairy queen and uh,
went in the back and where the drive
through is there was like a,
I don't know,
the dumpster and they got like the fence
around it and I just was able to open
it,
sit there and just cried basically
until,
uh,
so when we came out to throw away the
trash and then they were like,
oh,
how many got down and what do you need?
And all this other stuff.
Can you call your mom?
I'm like,
if I have a phone.
And so I walked inside,
called her,
but she wasn't there.
So it took a little while to get ahold
of my mom.
And then,
um,
yeah,
I mean it was just,
it was nuts because,
um,
it's weird how you,
you'll believe,
especially in today's age with social
media and all the tweets and things that
people just throw away.
I throw around,
um,
you know,
it's nuts how you can see something.
We don't even know him.
They might have one follower,
but somehow it can still,
if you let it,
it can still affect you instead of just
shrugging it off.
That's a totally different thing though.
So saying something on twitter and
someone saying something and looking you
in the eyes.
Yeah.
And planning out this big deception.
But you're such a nice guy.
Like I don't understand what,
what the fuck causes someone to be such
a shit head like that?
Well,
I don't know man.
I think,
well,
um,
I've,
I've matured a lot where,
I mean obviously 29 said 13,
but,
uh,
I think I just became an easy target and
because he's a nice guy and they just,
maybe I wouldn't stand up for myself and
maybe I wasn't the biggest kid,
but I was Chubby and bigger and,
uh,
yeah,
I think it just was easy to pick on me
in the locker rooms.
Pick on me.
And the,
I don't know.
I think,
I think the stats I was looking at with
something like 87% of bullying doesn't
happen in the presence of,
um,
adults,
adults.
Right.
And then,
uh,
I forget,
but you know,
even the people around like how you're
saying,
you know,
if to people plan it out and everything
else,
look in the eyes.
I mean I think that might've been what
took me back the most because I was
like,
man,
like this is,
if you're sitting by that,
this is what I tried to tell some of the
kiddos grown up.
Now it's like if you think that by
laughing I'm,
if you're there and you're not bullying
but you're giggling,
you're laughing.
Like you're definitely a part of it.
You're an encourager.
But then if you're,
even if you're silent and you're just
watching it and you don't,
like now your,
if you see it,
you have a choice,
you can do something about it.
You can not.
And so I feel like that's a passive
standby kind of encouragement where it,
and so for me it was like everyone was
there,
people were saying it,
people were laughing,
people were watching,
but nobody was standing up for me.
So it was a definitely,
that's what hurt the most.
We'll see.
So there's two giants says the one with
the other guy named Justin.
So they plan that out to fuck man.
Yeah.
Both kids.
It was actually part of the same kids,
so yeah.
Damn.
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
so from that,
um,
yeah,
that,
that's,
that's definitely been the biggest
battle of my life has been depression,
suicidal thoughts.
And it was all from that bullying.
There was nothing other than that for
the depression.
I mean,
it went from,
technically I would say it went from
third grade to 10th grade.
And then whenever I started wrestling
and my parents transferred me out of the
school,
everything else then,
but the bullying is what caused all
these suicidal thoughts.
There's nothing else that was bumming
you out about life that is so fucked up
at some shitty mean kids can all of a
sudden throw this monkey wrench in your
life.
And then I've,
I've learned,
and I mean,
of course I,
uh,
you know,
a lot.
I used to looking back,
I shouldn't have,
I shouldn't have ever let it get to the
point to where you know,
I think I should hurt myself or kill me.
You know what,
just a real quick put that together with
the pygmies and Congo,
whenever I opened up and shared with
some of them around the campfire,
just hanging out,
talking,
sharing life stories.
I shared that and I just remember the
looks on several people's faces just so
baffled.
Like did he just say he wanted to hurt
himself,
he was suicide.
He wanted to kill himself.
I'll let him and stuff.
And then my sister asking me,
does that not happen here?
And they're like,
whoa.
There's of them were like,
well we've heard of that happening
before and yeah,
there's,
there's this guy that was that guy and
that guy and that guy and we heard that
someone in their village had hurt
themselves or kill themselves or
something.
But most of the people I think were
like,
no,
never heard.
Why would anyone,
if you hurt yourself,
you're only like,
it's only hurting you.
Right.
That's not going to help anything.
But you just want the pain yet.
Yeah,
yeah.
Here I just wanted the pain to end.
But there it's like,
it's nuts because they,
if I look at it,
I was a little kid.
I got bullied by some,
some stupid kids,
and then look at,
if I look at what they're going through
me and it makes it,
it makes it,
it shrinks it,
it makes it microscopic.
Whenever you stop just focusing on your
own problems and you start looking at
others,
other problems that maybe you can be a
part of helping solve that problem.
So,
so this bullying all throughout your
childhood led into adulthood and the
only thing that made it better was you
go into the Congo and helping out these
pygmies and building wells and,
and sort of dedicating and devoting your
life to their life.
Yeah,
I would say practically,
um,
that has been,
you know,
to have a sense of purpose.
I mean,
I think it's a,
it's a lot of different things,
but that all kind of came together.
But for me.
Yeah.
I mean,
when you're not living for yourself and
you live in for others,
you just want,
I mean,
I didn't know that for me,
I had a big paradigm shift or change in
my life whenever,
you know,
coming out of the addiction,
I felt like,
I mean like I don't have to walk around
and hate myself and stay away from
people because they either going to hurt
me or I'm going to want to hurt them.
Like,
uh,
I don't have to do that.
I can,
I can help people.
I can want to love him.
I can,
you know,
figure out something that I did at first
started at what really started helping a
lot,
was involved with a lot of different
stuff from a juvenile detention center.
Going into meeting with some of those
kids once a week to a homeless shelter,
to becoming a official volunteer at the
Denver Children's hospital and taking
the grudge guys through there.
And did,
do you stay in any way in touch with
those kids from back in the day from the
kids who bullied you?
Did you ever,
it was actually funny,
after the ultimate fighter,
um,
I got invited out by one of the guys,
and,
uh,
just because I think a couple of people,
they'll just,
yeah,
it's all one of the guys who was one of
the main guys and he's like,
Hey,
I just saw him walking around downtown
Fort Worth.
And he said,
why don't we go out here?
Whatever.
I'm like,
all right,
I'll go.
And,
well,
he had actually,
uh,
brought me into,
the Sushi restaurant in all around the
table was most of the people that were
not most,
it's probably only eight or 10 people,
but they were some of the main kids that
were at that party when I dressed up and
everything.
Why?
Man,
if you,
if we had known you were a fighter or
you can kick their butts and we wouldn't
have done that to you.
And I'm just like it.
So I told him I was going to bathroom,
just left,
um,
from,
I think that's the only time I've ever
done anything like that,
but I'm just like,
I can't,
can't be around these guys.
Did.
Did you,
did you sense any feeling of remorse
from them or they just want to be
friends?
One new one or two of them?
Uh,
one guy for sure.
He's,
he's,
he's pretty cool now and um,
but then one is a,
is a knuckle head for sure and still,
yeah.
Picked up.
You know,
it's that classic thing of kids ganging
up on one kid.
That's a weird instinct that sometimes
children have.
You remember that movie carry on?
They uh,
she goes to the prom and the sea.
Did you ever say Shanti's basic moving?
It's based on a great Stephen King Book.
I knew that the cover,
the,
the sissies basic movie was really
trippy.
Uh,
John Travolta's in it.
Hmm.
Bagging the de young and handsome.
Um,
but it's,
you know,
that's the themes that they push her.
She has these crazy telekinetic powers
and they push her to this point and they
do it by mocking her and bullying her.
They take her to the prom,
they pour pig's blood on our hedge,
which winds up killing everybody.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
It was pretty,
pretty crazy.
But that's that thing that happens when
kids gang up on a kid that they feel
like is vulnerable.
Like what the fuck is that man?
What a horrible instinct take.
Is that,
what do I mean?
I,
I just,
I struggle to understand where that
instinct comes from or why people do it.
It's um,
especially little kids.
No,
I mean I,
I guess I can understand that if the
kids have been abused themselves and
they want to lash out there angry and
hurt,
but oftentimes it's just they find
someone who's a vulnerable,
it's like they find the pecking order
and they find the one person that can
get away with them.
They all funneled their insecurities and
their anger and their aggression on this
one person just because think with no
regard whatsoever,
what kind of impact it's going to have
on that kid.
Yeah.
I think,
I think one of the things that makes it
so much worse now is elite.
I mean,
I don't know.
I get to hear some of the stuff and they
can't escape it.
Like,
you know,
cause it follows him home.
I know that cyber bullying and they get
the text and the,
all that stuff is so,
it's constantly,
so I could at least escape it from eight
to three,
eight to three.
I was at school,
but when I came home,
I was,
I was okay.
And,
um,
maybe that gave me a break.
[inaudible]
yeah.